[Musica]
mi piace iniziare questo racconto
partendo da uno dei luoghi più
emozionanti della nostra fabbrica della
creatività di questo il luogo dove
vengono realizzati i costumi per tutte
le le opere per tutto quello che avviene
sul palcoscenico la sartori non luogo
importante magico speciale emozionante
perché racconta che cosa si può fare con
le mani cosa si può realizzare con un
valore importante che è quello della
manualità e così che grazie
all'esperienza anche alla trasmissione
di questo mestiere così antico è così
importante che abbiamo costruito la
storia del costume di questo teatro le
donne e gli uomini che sono passati di
qui nei secoli hanno lasciato la loro
impronta è trasferito il loro valore e
la loro conoscenza la loro competenza
oggi i tanti costumi sono stati
realizzati sono conservati nei nostri
depositi come hardy iena e sono oltre
10.000 pensate così come i bozzetti dei
costumisti importanti che sono passati
in questo teatro non penso ad arte penso
ai costumi realizzati per ingrid bergman
che ha fatto qui una giovanna d'arco con
la regia di rossellini
oggi è un grande giorno una grande
emozione perché finalmente questi
laboratori riprendono vita grazie alla
sapiente manualità delle nostre sarte
dei nostri sarti della direttrice del to
see giustino finalmente ci prepariamo ad
aprire al pubblico le porte del teatro
san carlo e così come potete vedere
attorno a me gli accessori che
serviranno per le protagoniste
di traviata che sarà lo spettacolo che
accoglierà il nostro pubblico
[Musica]
[Applauso]
siamo quindi il palco reale del teatro
san carlo
voglio ricordare che centro san carlo il
teatro più antico del mondo nel 1737 40
anni dopo cinquant'anni dopo verranno la
fenice la scala di milano
su questo palcoscenico si sono stati i
più grandi protagonisti dell'opera
lirica in questo teatro alle mie spalle
vedete questo schema meraviglioso che
rappresenta la lo stemma borbonico così
come potete vedere gli specchi che sono
collocati in ogni palchetto che sono
posizionati in modo da vedere
esattamente chi era qui nel palco reale
naturalmente del palco reale prendevano
posto i sovrani e la sua corte e solo
quando l'applauso partiva dal palco
reale gli altri potevano decretare il
successo di quello spettacolo tutta
questa bella storia
a un certo punto si è fermata si è
fermata per il covip per la pandemia ed
è stato come un terremoto
tutti sono scappati e hanno lasciato lì
tutto come era ricordo il palcoscenico
ancora con con le scene montate e
purtroppo non si è trattato di poco ma
di un lungo lunghissimo periodo quello
che ci è mancato di più è stato forse il
i rumori nel teatro il picchiettare sul
palcoscenico quando si costruisce uno
spettacolo o il vociare del pubblico
ecco il vociare del pubblico ha lasciato
un silenzio assordante e questo vuoto lo
abbiamo colmato con delle attività in
streaming che ci hanno aiutato a tenere
questo contatto fondamentale necessario
del teatro con le persone e lo abbiamo
fatto attraverso strumenti assolutamente
nuovi tutti si sono inventati attraverso
i telefonini o altri strumenti
questo contatto anche il teatro lo ha
fatto e lo ha fatto attraverso uno degli
strumenti più usati dal mondo intero che
facebook con facebook abbiamo deciso
a rappresentare il momento più
importante del teatro che
l'inaugurazione di una stagione e
presentarla al pubblico
e così che abbiamo realizzato a dicembre
cavalleria rusticana uno strumento
assolutamente nuovo che ci ha consentito
di arrivare in maniera trasversale ai
pubblici di tutto il mondo con un
biglietto politico che costava solo un
euro e 9 centesimi e che ha consentito
in maniera veramente democratica a tutti
di poter esplorare il teatro san carlo
[Musica]
questa esperienza è stata una esperienza
democratica direi importantissima perché
è un pubblico assolutamente trasversale
da tutto il mondo si è collegato e forse
per la prima volta potevano ammirare la
bellezza di questo teatro questo ci ha
fatto ripensare molto al futuro del
teatro perché sicuramente l'emozione
dello spettacolo dal vivo quello che ci
dà allo spettacolo dal vivo la bellezza
che ci abbraccia come potete vedere da
questo teatro è insostituibile
ciò detto altrettanto importante è la
possibilità che chiunque per ragioni
geografiche per ragioni anche di salute
possa connettersi e accedere al mondo
dell'opera
molto spesso si dice che le nuove
generazioni non arrivano in teatro
perché i biglietti sono cari perché il
teatro dell'opera è avvertito come
qualcosa per un pubblico più ricco e
quindi non democraticamente accessibile
e questo invece permette a tutti
veramente tutti di entrare in questo
teatro quindi siamo certi che nel
rivedere quale sarà il futuro del teatro
senza mai perdere l'essenza il carattere
educativo il carattere terapeutico del
teatro è importante che queste nuove
possibilità digitali possano convivere
con lo spettacolo dal vivo
e per questo che il teatro si sta
dotando di una piattaforma propria che
consentirà non solo di vivere il teatro
ma di vivere il territorio la città e
probabilmente in maniera democratica
quello che avviene dentro sarà trasmesso
con dei maxi schermi nei quartieri della
città e nelle maggiori province della
campania di tutta la storia di questo
teatro dal 1737 continuerà ad essere
fruita dal suo pubblico dei suoi
spettatori ancora per tante future
generazioni
e lo farà con questi nostri ripensamenti
verso il futuro attraverso strumenti
anche diversi con un palcoscenico
davvero aperto al mondo